when I look at other big threes I don't  necessarily look at them and say oh man  they have this on us or they have that  on us it's almost impossible to compare  if you look at the Lakers everybody's  going to say Shaq and Kobe right like  but Derek Fisher was so important to  those teams and they couldn't win  without Derek Fisher magic Kareem and  James Worthy I'm sorry yeah  you look at D Wade bronze and Bosch I  wouldn't necessarily pick them over us  but box is 611 LeBron is six nine  there's just facts yeah d-way six four  yeah 225 but when you get down to  itty-gritty I ain't picking nobody  over us three none of those guys face  the same challenges that we Face Steph  was too slow and handles weren't good  enough and Clay couldn't dribble good  enough and I was just way too fat and  too slow with no position like those  groups and that's why I'm picking us